and dear fellow Scholars this is two
minute papers with Dr Carol jonai fahir
yes that's right Microsoft's new AI
watched about a hundred million clips
from YouTube and today we are going to
ask one simple question what did it
learn I'll tell you in a moment you see
today text to image AIS are all their
age by just doing as little as entering
a tax prompt we can create all kinds of
images and even videos a true Miracle of
science really and I often hear people
saying that they can't wait to be able
to express their creativity by creating
movies with them however not so fast we
can already do that with Googles and
runways technique and there are even
more out there but for some reason I
rarely hear people talking about sound
well this new paper solves exactly that
now wait a minute we are going to evoke
the second law of papers here which says
that whatever you are thinking about
there is already a two minute papers
episode on that for instance we talked
about Google's music LM an incredible AI
based technique that takes a text prompt
and synthesizes incredible music listen
[Music]
and dance
is fantastic also our seasoned fellow
Scholars remember an earlier episode
where we talked about a brilliant
handcrafted graphics paper that did
something that was previously thought to
be almost impossible so what is that
well hold on to your papers because it
took an already existing video clip or
computer animation and synthesized
sounds for it and the results were
outstanding yes through the power of
computer Graphics research this was
possible approximately 10 years ago yes
you heard it right this paper was
published 10 years ago at the seagraph
conference that is an incredible place
which similarly high quality papers now
with all that said what does this new AI
paper add to the mix and I would say
everything now I hear you asking doctor
what do you mean by this well exactly
what I said this is an any to any
generation technique that also includes
audio here are some of my favorite
examples one if we enter a piece of text
like fireworks in the sky it synthesizes
video and audio at the same time
or we can write dive in a coral reef and
we get this
two we can also go the other way around
if we have a text description of a
painterly style and look no mention of
ships at all and we also add this sound
sample
we get this image so cool but wait it
gets even better three we can even enter
a tax prompt plus a piece of audio and
out comes not just an image but oh my
even a piece of video as requested the
camera indeed goes forward ever so
slightly good job little Ai and we can
also perform the usual suspect text to
image a piece of audio to an image or if
we have a cracking photo we can even ask
it to create a video with a somewhat
similar Vibe wow it feels like this can
do absolutely everything now every
single one of you fellow Scholars see
that the quality of these results is not
the greatest however remember two years
ago we had Dolly one for image
generation a year later Dolly 2 and now
a year later me Journey can do this and
I would not be surprised if today we
would be at a dolly one moment for full
film or in other words video plus audio
generation just imagine what we will be
capable off just two more papers down
the line my goodness what a time to be
alive and if you don't mind I just can't
resist quickly showing a really cool
computer graphics paper to you this is a
new technique that is able to simulate
situations with a brutally large number
of collisions these simulations contain
objects that are built up from millions
and millions of tetrahedra little
pyramids if you will for instance when
squishing this ball it can simulate what
happens next incredible it can also
simulate Davy Jones and his friends
falling into a glass box and other
complex naughty situations all this in a
matter of seconds absolutely incredible
Graphics research sorry I just couldn't
resist showing this to you I hope you
fellow Scholars don't mind let me know
in the comments below weights and biases
provides tools to track your experiments
in your your deep learning projects what
you see here is that tables feature and
the best part about it is that it is not
only able to handle pretty much any kind
of data you can throw at it but it also
presents your experiments to you in a
way that is easy to understand it is
used by many prestigious Labs including
open AI Toyota research GitHub and more
and the best part is that weights and
biases is free for all individuals
academics and open source projects make
sure to visit them through wnb.com
papers or just click the link in the
video description and you can get a free
demo today our thanks to weights and
biases for their long-standing support
and for helping us make better videos
for you thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time